and let's welcome in the gorilla glue
toughest player on planet earth for this
week
from just up the road he played his high
school ball from here in inglewood
california so it's an honor to have here
and the el segundo studios on the phone
from
kansas the man who just helped beat
texas none other than
red shirt quarterback jaylen daniels he
is our winner this week
thank you thank you thank you yeah
wow
that's the only word for it
wow all right let's just start with when
did you learn you were gonna start this
week
for kansas against texas at texas
uh so at the beginning of the week um
is when i really found out you know
really just being able to prepare for
the game you know not really knowing
what was really going to go what was
really going to happen you know going
into the texas week uh i believe monday
or tuesday is when i found out
officially and you know just really
trying to rally up the troops you know
um everybody had my support on the team
offensively and defensively and we were
just able to you know go out there
saturday and be able to perform i should
say so two touchdowns in your career
coming in
three in this game against texas alone
uh how did you
handle just stepping out on that field
at texas for a kansas team that had one
on the road in conference
in 2000 since 2008
um
how did you handle the moment
you know definitely just just the
support of my teammates you know um uh
lineman like you know mike nowitzki just
coming up to me saying we have you 100
you know we're going to protect you up
front you know just be able just play
your game you know uh devin neal being
able to play uh
a lot of serious snaps this year you
know
being able to score touchdowns he's
always had faith in me since before he
even got here uh talking to devin neal
before he got here was definitely very
essential for me and his bond coming
into this season
and you know just having the support
from everybody else
and then let's let's get uh through the
game here so you're up big but can't uh
texas ties it
and it's time for overtime what did your
coach say to you and the team
as you're getting ready for your game
you know uh i act like you've been here
before you know just be able to
you know maintain what you've been doing
no matter what it is you know uh coming
into this program with coach lipo one
thing that he that he emphasized when he
got here was was when adversity strikes
how are you going to respond you know
he goes by something that we
refer to as e plus r equals o which is
event plus response equals outcome how
are you going to respond and when
adversity strikes how are you going to
respond to that situation i'm more
verbal than math i did better on the
verbal than my sats than math
but i get that one i totally still get
that one jalen so
okay so overtime starts texas gets the
ball they score
kick the extra point
it's time for you to respond you score
and coach lipaul holds up the fingers
for two go for two was there a
conversation about that at all you know
there was no conversation before we went
to two went for two uh i believe that
coach lipo just has a great amount of
trust in us with the offensive unit
um and that just shows how much trust
that he has in us as players on our team
and just us as a program
and so okay you go for two i'll be
honest with you i'm watching this i
thought the play was dead i really did
certainly since you damn near faded back
out of the red zone so
uh and then
walk me through that moment for you and
of course the story that many people are
hearing about this week is who you threw
it to and who caught it i'll give you
the floor jalen daniels on that please
you know uh coach k decided to call one
of the plays that you know i really had
a great feel for coming into that week
of practice um so he decided to call
that play uh i've seen man coverage to
the field
and i eventually got pushed out of the
pocket so i had to roll out to the right
um i eventually was able to see jared
casey you know coming in the middle of
the of the end zone waving his hands
wide open and i was just able to make a
make a throw in between some defenders
and he just made a great catch for the
game-winning touchdown and i'm so proud
of him you know just being able to see
all the work that he's put in you know
he's in the same class as me
as a walk-on and that's something that i
didn't even know until coming into this
season uh because of the amount of of
plays that he makes in practice you know
jared has made a lot of miraculous plays
in practice and the fact that he was
able to come into the game
in a game that he said he didn't even
know that he was going to be able to
play in and just
make a great play that's just something
that we're all so proud of and it's his
first catch ever
it's unbelievable it's your first start
there right you didn't know until that
week that you're starting you had two
touchdowns coming in
in your kansas career you had three in
the game you go for two you beat texas
at texas give kansas their first dub on
the road in conference since 2008 by
throwing a walk-on or never caught a
pass before
that's all true right
that's it's really crazy because um you
know a lot of people uh say that
he's just a walk-on and stuff like that
but you know when your name is called
and
one thing that i i always you know grew
up with the motto is is a baller's gonna
ball you know um especially when the
time is right you know when you get that
chance take advantage of it you know
that that's something that we we harp on
as a as a team you know
when you when your numbers called up are
you going to be ready for it and then
when you when your number is caught up
just make the play
did did you knock him down in the
celebration was that you or somebody no
that wasn't me who wants because
somebody knocked him down in the
celebration somebody took him out
so
i mean this is just amazing the whole
country has seen this and i i'm thrilled
that you're winning this award this week
to know your story how does a kid from
lawndale high in inglewood get to kansas
how did that happen oh um
uh coming coming to london you know i
had head coach travis clark you know
definitely a coach who was always on me
you know always wanted me to be able to
reach my goals so
um junior year we were able to pull out
a state championship
senior year is um when we lost i believe
second or third round in the playoffs
you know definitely
a hard time to go through you know
especially since i had just won a state
championship the year before um but mid
season
through uh mid-season my senior year
kansas uh begins you know just start
start recruiting me telling me about um
telling me about their program and
everything and
one
the week after they started to talk to
me was the texas game in 2019
um and that game was was a very crazy
crazy game crazy atmosphere
uh made it down to the last few seconds
of the game uh just like this year did
so um like like i said uh
told carter stanley who was the
quarterback of that 2019 team was
uh that game was something that
really inspired me to want to come to
kansas you know be able to
help turn around a program with with my
teammates here you know um and watching
that game i believe i watched that game
five plus times the week of texas game
and it just kept motivating me i even
spoke to my teammates about that game
and they were just like
let's go out here and let's finish what
that 2019 that 2019 team started
i love it jalen you just you you you get
it man so
and by the it now this nil deal uh from
gorilla glue that we're thrilled to be
able to present to you is this your
first is this your first nil deal yes
sir all right
what are you gonna do with the glue what
needs fixing around your your spot jalen
you know um growing up gorilla glue was
something that i always had in in my uh
in my drawer in my kitchen you know okay
if i ever needed some glue my grandma
would be like there's some gorilla glue
in the in the
drawer in the kitchen so you know
the fact that uh i'm i'm able to be
blessed with this opportunity you know
it's just something that i'm really
blessed for you know telling my grandma
about it
and being able to see the smile on her
face through a video camera was just
everything to me you know
one thing i will say is i like to make
my family proud you know
seeing the smiles on my on my family's
face you know just motivates me to be
to try to be a better person than i was
yesterday
so you're gonna give the glue to your
grandmother because you took you took
hers now you now you give her yours is
that is this the circle of life that
we're talking about right now is that
possible can we do that
[Laughter]
well um just one last one for you is it
is it and i don't mean to you know stir
anything up but is it possible you you
lose your red shirt here
um what do you think
one thing that i that i said after the
game was i want to be able to build you
know one one reason why i did commit to
kansas was to be able to turn around a
program you know
at the beginning of the year i also said
that it was really about
self-development you know uh being able
to progress no matter what what
situation it is just be able to progress
and when your time comes
you know take advantage of it you know
um
winning this texas game meant a lot for
us as a team you know being able to
build momentum and going into the tcu
week you know it's just a lot of a lot
of energy in the building
a lot of energy from the offensive
defense and either way it didn't matter
if my red shirt stayed or not everybody
on i believe in this building has
complete faith in me and they respect i
respect either decision that was made
well um you're you're already there man
you gave me an answer without giving me
an answer that you're you're very good
you are very very good at this
jalen daniels
congratulations on your performance this
week and on this award i love hearing
how you are connected with your family
in this way that's what it's about right
family football faith people mentioned
the three f's and now i learned what e
plus what equals o what is that again
plus r equals o event plus response
equals the outcome oh how are you going
to respond when adversity strikes there
it is i'm gonna pick that one up i'm
gonna run with that one congratulations
on on all of this and and look for my
call i'd love to stay in touch and see
how you you uh progress in what your
dream is and what your plan is yes sir
definitely thank you i really do
appreciate it there you go everybody
kansas quarterback jaylen daniels this
week's gorilla glue toughest player on
planet earth
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here